На початку березня гривня щодо євро і долара стрімко зміцнилася,
бо перед виборами навмисно "вкидається" бага то грошей.
Про це писали у деяких ЗМІ та соцмережах.
Натомість Національний банк запевняє, що "курс гривні визначається ринком"
і ніхто його "спеціально не утримує".
Порівняно з початком року курс гривні щодо долара зміцнився на початку березня більш ніж на гривню
і здолав психологічну позначку 27 гривень за один "зелений".
Попри стрибки "вгору-вниз" на 20 і більше копійок
тенденція зміцнення гривні в напрямку 26 гривень за долар стабільно продовжувалась,
хоча останніми днями гривня знову різко "просіла".
Опитані DW експерти нещодавнє зміцнення гривні пояснюють сезонністю.
Це вже традиція: навесні гривня зміцнюється, а восени слабшає.
Приміром, рівно рік тому долар взагалі був по 25.9.
В першу чергу така сезонність відбувається через випуск облігацій внутрішніх державних позик
у гривнях під високий відсоток.
Тож, іноземним інвесторам вигідно обміняти долари на гривні та вкластися в цінні папери.
За січень-лютий цього року іноземні інвестори збільшили цей "портфель" більш ніж на 10 відсотків -
до майже 13 мільярдів гривень.
Друга причина - традиційна аграрна сезонність в Україні.
Фермери починають готуватися до посівної та продають накопичені долари.
Причому, як правило, це готівка.
І третя важлива причина - ситуація на зовнішніх ринках сприятлива для українського експорту.
Передусім, це аграрна і металургійна продукція.
Ціни на пшеницю і кукурудзу дещо впали, але це компенсували високі ціни на метали.
Підвищення пенсій та зарплат чи виплата субсидій готівкою,
а також зміна позицій лідерів президентських перегонів за результатами соцопитувань
не впливають на курс гривні, стверджують експерти.
Один з показників того, що гривня штучно підтримується від падіння -
це продаж Нацбанком золотовалютних резервів.
Але донині Нацбанк фактично грав проти гривні
і навпаки скуповував валюту, щоб не було надто різкого зміцнення.
З початку року Нацбанк купив 700 мільйонів доларів,
причому понад 200 з них - за перший тиждень березня.
Політика плаваючого обмінного курсу продовжується.
Курс гривні справді станом на зараз не "тримають" до виборів.
Стрімке зміцнення гривні спричинили сезонні фактори в економіці та фінансах,
а не політичні причини.
Очікувати суттєвих "гривнепадів", попри те, що гривня останніми днями різко "просіла",
найближчим часом не варто, вважають експерти.
Але припускають: результат виборів може призвести до переміщення капіталу,
що потягне за собою і зміну курсу гривні.
Восени ж, як і в попередні роки, гривня традиційно буде слабшати
і середній курс долара за 2019 рік очікується приблизно на рівні 29 гривень.